welcome back aspiring professional
python devs to M coding I'm James Murphy
let's learn how to set up logging in
your python application the modern way
that means we're going to learn to stop
doing this and start doing this
instead as always with so-called best
practices these are General guidelines
that work for most use cases however you
know what's best for your code way
better than I do so if you have a good
reason then do what you know is right
don't blindly follow this advice if it
doesn't work for you you with that said
let's get going right after I sponsor
myself at M coding we do code reviews
Consulting and Professional Training do
you have a problem with your code
worried about your architecture or do
you just need some extra Dev hours why
not make me part of your team anyway
let's get back to logging the built-in
logging package is very old and full of
stuff that you shouldn't use it doesn't
follow pep eight the docs are a mess and
many tutorials are outdated or quite
frankly written by people who obviously
don't use it but for all its quirks the
built-in logging package is the defacto
standard for logging in Python it
doesn't matter if you're using a cloud
provider or just developing a local
application the standard is the built-in
logging package but do you really even
need logging at all hey man you came to
me if your app doesn't need logging
that's up to you I'm just here to show
you what's possible all right let's see
how to get
started you might think you just import
logging make a logger set it up with a
basic config and then get to logging
with your messages when you run the
codee based off the log level you set
you see those level messages end
worse and I wouldn't blame you if you've
been doing it this way in the most basic
cases this is totally fine but I don't
really recommend doing it this
way why well if you care to do logging
at all you probably want to log to at
least two different places like to
standard out and also to a file or you
want to log higher priority things like
errors and exceptions differently maybe
you want to send an email if there's an
exception thrown in prod
you can manually make handlers and
filters and add them to your loggers but
trust me just don't do it that way
instead use dict config for some reason
dict config is hidden away in this
loging doc config subm module and not so
much as mentioned in the main logging
docs as the name suggests this lets you
configure logging via a dictionary that
explicitly lists all of the necessary
components of your logging setup namely
the filters formatters handlers and
loggers the basic config hides these
objects and their relationships from you
which makes for a really slick oneliner
in the most basic case but for more
useful logging setups I find it's much
clearer to list them
explicitly it can get really confusing
if you don't have a good mental model
for what these things actually do so
here's the one picture to keep in mind
to see how it all fits
together loggers are the things that you
actually use in your code they have
ainfo and you can call logger dotinfo to
log a message logger debug to log a
debug message logger exception to log
the inflight exception
Etc that creates a log record which is
an object that contains all kinds of
useful contextual information things
like the message and severity the
current time the current thread or async
task the location and the source code
and so on every logger can set a level
to drop all messages below a certain
severity and optionally some filters to
drop or alter messages along the way so
you could do something like drop all
messages that begin with some annoying
string or you could do something more
sophisticated like sensor private user
data that isn't supposed to appear in
logs the logger then passes these log
records off to each of their handlers
one at a
time handlers tell you how and where to
log a record like to standard out to a
file over email or to a commercial log
service each Handler receives the log
record and just like for loggers the
Handler has a level and some filters
that allow it to drop drop or alter the
message along the
way if a record is dropped by a Handler
it still passes on to the rest of the
handlers but if it was dropped by the
logger itself then it's dropped for
good assuming the message passes through
the levels and filters when it comes
time for the Handler to actually write
the log message it needs to write text
but currently this is a python object so
each Handler has a formatter that it
uses to convert the log record object
into a string to be sent out the
formatter is lets you customize what an
individual message looks like like is it
the log level and then the message or
level then timestamp then message or
maybe you write Json or maybe you write
some other format formatters are
typically where you see the most
customization because it's the formatter
that selects which data from the log
record to actually include in the
message and that depends a lot on your
specific use case and what you want to
see in your logs and this is almost the
complete picture except this is the
picture for the root logger the root as
in the root of the tree of
loggers loggers are accessed and created
by name and if you split the name by
dots then you end up with a tree of
loggers so the a.x logger is a child of
the A- logger which is a child of the
root by default once a child's done
handling a log record it passes that
record up to its parent so if this log
record was generated down here in the
a.x logger all of a. X's handlers would
run then it would propagate up to a and
all of A's handlers would run then it
would propagate up to the root and all
of the roots handlers would run this is
done to make it easier for users to
disable messages from Whole subsystems
just by disabling certain
loggers once again if a record is
dropped by a Handler it will continue
moving on to include propagating up to
the parent but if it's dropped by a
logger then it stops and doesn't
propagate but slow down there this is
way more flexibility than you would
usually need having all these handlers
and filters and propagation at different
levels is unnecessarily complex for most
use cases and it often leads to subtly
broken
configs so here's what I recommend see
all these non-root handlers delete them
unless you've got a good reason put all
handlers on the root
logger this is simpler but also having
all handlers on the root logger ensures
that any messages generated by
thirdparty libraries get logged and
formatted the same way as messages
generated by your own
application filters same deal there's a
decent chance you don't need any filters
at all but if you do put them all on the
root logger or their
handlers leave propagation turned on
which is the default so that all
messages propagate up to the root
logger however don't use the root logger
in your
code if you use any of the top level
logging functions like logging doino
this uses is the root logger so don't
use any of those
functions make sure to use your own
logger which you get by using loging
doget logger and passing in the name of
the logger that you want this will
create the logger first if it doesn't
already exist then you can use your
logger dotinfo instead of logging doino
and remember your logger doesn't have
any handlers on it we're depending on
propagation to send all events up to the
root logger and have the root logger
actually handle the events if you have a
small to mediumsized application a
single non-root logger is all you need
if you have a very large application
then you should make one non-root logger
for each major subcomponent of your
application you definitely don't need a
logger for every file that'd be a waste
because these are globals that live for
the entire life of the program with that
all in mind let's get back to
configuring logging for a few common
setups using dict
config as a baseline let's just have a
simple config that logs everything to
standard out if you're ever confused
about the config draw it out like this
and then use the picture to fill in the
config this version is required and the
only valid value is one this is so that
they can change everything in the future
without breaking old code disable
existing loggers does what it says it
disables anything that's not explicitly
listed in this config I'm going to go
ahead and set this to false so that I
can get log messages from third party
code no filters in this configuration so
let's just delete that next Define a
formatter named simple and give it a
simple format string we didn't specify
what class this formatter is so by
default it just uses the built-in
logging do formatter it accepts the
format string like this using this kind
of weird print F style format string yes
it's kind of weird but just deal with it
or foreshadowing wait a minute and we'll
see a better
way if you want to customize your own
format you can find a list of all the
available variables in the loging
documentation next we need to define the
single standard out Handler
so we create this single Handler named
Standard out and set our simple
formatter as the formatter for this
Handler in order to get it to actually
log to standard out we set its class to
the built-in logging stream Handler with
a stream of system. standardout the x/
slash here means external as in this is
a variable that's defined outside of
this
config and voila in just 16 lines we've
configured what the basic config did in
one
line I know I know but keep in mind this
more of aose style is going to be a lot
clearer when we have more going on so
stick with me despite the fact that
we're using di config that doesn't mean
that we need to keep the login
configuration as a literal dictionary in
our python Source nothing wrong with
that but many find it convenient to keep
the login config in a separate file in
Json or yaml format personally I prefer
to keep my config in Json so go ahead
and create a Json version of your config
then load that Json when when your
application
starts if you wanted to use yaml instead
it would look basically the same except
of course you would have a yaml config
and you would import yaml and do a yl
load instead of a Json load let's bring
those side by side just so you can see
the two
configs obviously yaml is a lot more
condensed but I find it to be a lot more
error prone as well and also there's no
yaml parer built into python whereas
there is a built-in Json
parser so if you wanted to you would
have to pull that in as a dependency p
is a popular choice keeping the log
config in a separate file also allows
you to let your users adjust the loging
to their preference you know if you
trust your users to do that kind of
thing second setup let's modify the
config so that errors go to standard
error and then all logs go to a
file change the standard out Handler to
standard error and set its level to
warning then create a new Handler and
set its class to a rotating file Handler
a rotating file Handler keeps appending
logs to a file until it reaches a
certain size in this case 10
kilobytes after it reaches 10 kilobytes
it creates a backup and starts a new
file after three backups it starts
deleting the oldest
one 10 kilobytes is a pretty small limit
this is just so that you can see the
roll over happen you probably want to
pick a few
[Applause]
megabytes
after running the script a bunch of
times you can see it eventually created
this mya. log. one and then started
using my app. log again we're still
using the simple formatter here but
since we're saving to a log file why
don't we include some extra
details we accomplished that by adding
this new detailed formatter and setting
it as the formatter for the file Handler
we include much more information in the
format string and we're also showing off
the date form format here which allows
us to customize how dates are printed
Pro tip use an ISO 8601 compliant format
and include the time zone trust
me this way our log contains a lot more
useful contextual information for a lot
of applications this is a great place to
stop but if you really care about the
quality of your log data then I really
suggest making one crucial change take a
look at this log file glancing over it I
can visually distinguish different
messages from each other but notice that
we have tracebacks in here and what if
log messages had new lines in them if I
wanted to parse this programmatically
I'd need to be able to parse back out
all of the data that I put into it but
it's kind of just in free form text with
new lines that could be anywhere at this
point that's kind of
intractable the solution store
persistent logs in Json format so that
they can be parsed easily later on this
is a change in how to convert a log
record into a string so that's the job
of the formatter we need a Json
formatter but oh wait there's no
built-in logging Json
formatter there are a few you can pip
install but let's just write our own
supposing we did you'd think you'd be
able to just set the class key here and
then pass in whatever arguments here and
those will be keyword arguments to the
Constructor that's what's happening here
with the Handler
right uh nope you can use your own class
here using the class keyword but if you
do then all of the keys are hardcoded to
be the ones that the built-in uses so I
could use format and date format but I
couldn't create my own format Keys why
is it like this way great question
moving on change class to open close pen
and then it will do what you actually
want call this and pass this as a
keyword argument you'd have to do the
same thing anywhere else in the config
like if I made my own custom Handler
that didn't have the same interface as
the built-in
one okay well with that weird Road bump
out of the way let's continue so we're
going to pass in these format Keys which
is going to be a dictionary where the
key is the key that I want to appear in
the log message and the value here like
level name is the variable that we're
going to look up from the log
record okay so let's go ahead and write
this class we're in a new file here and
we just inherit from the built-in loging
formatter nothing special in the init we
just store the format keys that we get
from the config then we need to Define
this format function this is a thing
that takes the record and goes to a
string I'm using override here to
indicate that we're overriding something
from the parent class it's not strictly
necessary but it's a good habit to get
into marking these things all we do is
extract out the record data into a
dictionary and then use the Json module
to dump that to a
string as far as actually extracting
those fields goes it's pretty simple
simple regardless of the config I chose
to include the message and a time stamp
in ISO format in UTC time zone we pull
in any exception data if it's present
using some parent methods in order to
extract things out nicely and for the
rest of the keys we just grab them from
the attributes of the record it's pretty
straightforward and you could probably
do whatever you want
here and dunzo update the config to use
the new Json formatter and we're good to
go check our log file and we see nicely
formatted
Json a slight warning though this file
is not valid Json each line is valid
Json this format is called Json lines
and the common file extension is Json l
so to parse it you just read the file
line by line and parse each line as Json
and double Pro tip now that we're
outputting Json it's actually really
easy to add lots of extra contextual
information to do this we can just use
the extra argument in one of our log
calls give it a dictionary of extra
information and python will stuff that
onto the log record then just update
your formatter to pull in those extra
attributes and now any extras will
appear in our Json here's the X
hello if you're getting too many logs
and you'd like finer control over which
ones to drop then you might need a
filter the process of creating a custom
filter is very similar to creating a
custom formatter inherit from the
built-in filter then Define your own
override of the filter function
given a record you return a pool to
indicate whether or not that record
should be processed so this non-error
filter does kind of the opposite of
setting the level to info setting the
level to info would mean that you would
only keep messages that were info
warning error critical but setting this
non-error filter would give you debug
and info instead you can also alter the
record here like if you wanted to censor
private data or return an altered copy
I'm not going to deal with filters for
the rest of the video but here's a
homework exercise using this non-error
filter create a login config that shows
normal messages to standard out but
error messages to standard error you're
going to need the filter to prevent
duplicates okay okay surely there are no
more glaring flaws with this logging
setup right at the risk of using a
forbidden word in Python let's talk
about performance by its very nature
calling a log function results in Io if
a user makes a request to my web app
and that results in 10 log messages I
don't want to add 10 round trips worth
of time to my logging service before I
respond to my user but currently that's
what will happen because all login calls
are synchronous and blocking the
solution use a q Handler to log off the
main thread collecting log data isn't
the slow part the slow part is sending
it wherever it needs to go a q Handler
stores your log records in a que without
blocking while an Associated Q listen ER
accepts those messages and passes them
off to other handlers in another thread
in order to configure this create a new
Q Handler in your config the class is
logging handlers Q Handler and then it
accepts another list of handlers these
are the handlers that it dispatches to
so basically take the handlers that you
had on the root Handler before put them
here and then change the Q Handler to be
your only Handler on the
route this respect Handler level for for
some reason is by default false which
results in the behavior of sending every
message to every Handler regardless of
log level so yeah that's probably not
what we want and I'm going to set this
to true so that it does what you expect
there's one more thing we need to handle
over here in the main file which is that
because the Q Handler is starting a
thread that's not something that's going
to happen automatically when we set up
our logging we need to manually start
that
thread we accomplish this by getting the
Q Handler by name and then if it exists
we start its listeners
thread we also register an add exit call
back in order to call The Listener stop
method and shut it down gracefully when
the program ends alternatively if you
want to keep all the work inside the
config you could also subclass the Q
Handler class and make it do this stuff
in its knit and success we finally have
highquality parsable multi-destination
non-blocking logging setup for our
python application feels good doesn't
it but notice I said logging for your
application not your library application
authors know who their users are and
know what kind of logs that they want to
see whereas if you're writing Library
code you don't know who your end user is
and you don't know what kind of logs
they want conclusion for Library code
don't configure
logging you can still use logging create
loggers log messages and other important
events just don't configure it with dick
config or any other config let
applications do the configuring if a
user doesn't configure logging the
default and expected behavior is that
warnings and above will be printed to
standard error if a user of your library
does configure logging then don't
interfere with what they want by adding
handlers formatters or other things that
they're not aware of finally do you
remember log for J it's an extremely
popular logging library for Java that
had a zero day vulnerability wreak havoc
and caus absolute pandemonium in the
business world as thousands of large
products and services with millions or
billions of users instantly became
vulnerable to an easy-to-do remote
arbitrary code execution
vulnerability at the heart of the
vulnerability was a combination of
logging user input combined with a
plugin that allowed loading remote data
as Java object data anyway here's
Python's make log record function that
can be used to create log records
manually for example from a pickled
event received over the
wire I'm not saying this is actively
vulnerable but in case logging for p
becomes a thing called it thanks for
watching and remember my company is M
coding so if you're still not satisfied
with your logging or other project setup
maybe we can help don't be afraid to
reach out did you know that this entire
channel is funded completely by
donations so huge thanks to everyone on
patreon and direct contributors for
supporting the channel if you'd like to
support the channel go to
number of times see you in the next one